mais il y avait d'autres flics
qui étaient honorés à l'idée de s'associer avec la communauté,
qui se sentaient responsables d'être capables
de travailler avec les chefs de la communauté et les chefs religieux
afin de réduire la violence dans la communauté.
C'était également le cas des officiers de probation,
des juges,
des gens faisant partie de la chaîne d'application de la loi,
parce que, comme nous, ils réalisaient
que les arrestations ne nous sortiraient pas de cette situation,
qu'il n'y aurait pas assez de poursuites judiciaires,
et que les prisons ne seront jamais suffisamment remplies
pour résoudre le problème.
J'ai aidé à former une organisation,
il y a 20 ans, une organisation fondée sur la foi, pour gérer le problème.
Je l'ai quittée il y a environ 4 ans,
j'ai commencé à travailler dans des villes partout aux Etats-Unis,
19 villes au total,
et j'ai découvert que, dans ces villes,
il y avait toujours un même facteur, des chefs de communauté
qui baissaient la tête et s'affairaient,
qui laissaient leur ego à l'entrée
et voyaient le tout comme plus grand que la somme des parties,
se rassemblaient et trouvaient comment travailler avec les jeunes dans la rue,
que la solution n'était pas plus de policiers,
mais exploiter les atouts qui sont dans la communauté,
avoir un lien communautaire fort
dans la collaboration pour réduire la violence.
Il y a un mouvement aux Etats-Unis,
des jeunes dont je suis très fier, qui gèrent les problèmes structuraux
qui ont besoin d'être réglés pour être une meilleure société.
Mais il y a ce stratagème politique qui essaye d'opposer la brutalité policière
et les mauvais comportements avec la violence entre noirs.
Mais c'est de la fiction.
Tout est lié.
Quand vous pensez à des décennies d'échec des programmes de logements sociaux
et aux structures éducatives médiocres,
quand vous pensez au chômage persistant
et au sous-emploi dans une communauté,
au système de sécurité sociale lamentable,
et que vous y mêlez la drogue
et des sacs en papier remplis d'armes,
il n'est pas étonnant de voir émerger cette culture de la violence.
Et la réponse de l'Etat est de mettre plus de policiers
et de supprimer les quartiers chauds.
Tout est lié,
et l'une des choses merveilleuses que nous avons pu faire
a été de montrer la valeur d'un rassemblement, d'un partenariat --
la communauté, les représentants de la loi, le secteur privé, la ville --
afin de réduire la violence.
Vous devez accorder de la valeur à ce facteur communautaire.
Je pense que nous pouvons mettre un terme à l'ère de la violence dans nos villes.
Je pense que c'est possible et que des gens le font en ce moment.
Mais j'ai besoin de votre aide.
Cela ne peut pas seulement venir de personnes qui s'épuisent
dans la communauté.
Ils ont besoin de soutien. Ils ont besoin d'aide.
Retournez dans votre ville.
Trouvez ces personnes.
« Vous avez besoin d'aide ? Je vais vous aider. »
Trouvez ces personnes. Elles sont là.
Rassemblez-les avec les représentants de la loi, le secteur privé et la ville,
avec pour but de réduire la violence,
mais assurez-vous que le lien communautaire est fort.
Parce que le vieil adage venant de Burundi est vrai :
ce que vous faites pour moi, sans moi, vous me le faites.
Dieu vous bénisse. Merci.
(Applaudissements)